dans un instant il y aura l'hélium de
l'actu oui j'ai de la piscine
j'ai donné lieu au mi6 voilà jadin j'ai
bien mais pas besoin d'apprendre comment
nous a fait rêver
comment nous faudra mais c'est pas la
peine mais si tous les deux on s'adore
c'est son retour aujourd'hui
et merde c'est son ça tombera pas plus
bas c'est son retour aujourd'hui je
redemande applaudir la belle
[Applaudissements]
les hommes de la tuque a laissé entendre
ce matin yannick letranchant le
directeur de l'information de france
télévisions pour donner la réponse soit
dans la langue je vais vous donner des
pour des propositions une prochaine
réduction du budget de cash et
investigations la fin de 19 heures le
dimanche avec laurent delahousse
l'allongement du 13h de 10 minutes ou
l'allongement de 5 cm de david [ __ ]
faites attention ne fait pas trop de
bruit
ouais alors allez-y dans et tout pour
inspirer alors il s'agit dans lequel six
futurs excusez moi et sa fidèle à sa
guise d'argument cherche à la fin de vie
ce n'est pas du genre c'est pas possible
de l'hélium gestion en 2011 johnny
hallyday n'est fait un testament en
faveur de la vie dès lors à la fidl et
isla
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi avait fait un testament en faveur
donc de david et laura david et lætitia
david et joyce jonathan fait vous avez
la même voie oui nous sommes à isabelle
[Applaudissements]
eh oui
on a compris elle a dit qu'elle aura
exactement
alléché rythme a dit oui quel clip vient
d'être présentée dans une nouvelle
version afin d'aider le sidaction
sa raison d'être qui a le droit je
marche seul où le papa pingouin
c'est alors oui sa raison d'être
oui on fait nos petits coups c'est sa
raison d'être trouvé ton bleu c'est ça